so are you cool like with the can you
you can have three wives we can have
four wives my dad um my dad has two
wives so yeah
no that's so that's so interesting what
was that like I really liked it I mean
it's not it wasn't easy for everybody
but
um yeah so like what
um I have a family I have four brothers
and sisters in Pakistan and I've got me
and my five in uh England and um we
didn't know for quite a bit of our lives
and then we kind of got introduced later
on and so on and so forth but you didn't
know we didn't know for a little while
wait how because I think my mom was
trying to Shield us from it because it's
so unfamiliar to her but it was familiar
in my dad's kind of like a region where
he's from and she was kind of shielding
us from it but then we wanted to
introduce and blend the families that I
really like the idea of having extra
siblings